kelly on a quelqu'un qui est venu vous
voir il y vous venez de pleurer ce que
vous avez vu votre ami qu'est devenu
votre cousine à la force des choses il
ya quelqu'un qui vous voir ciani qui me
veut du bien ou du mal vous voulez tous
les deux du bien apparemment votre plat
préféré
ce n'est pas la bouillabaisse mais la
soupe de langues
salima ouais d'accord
keddy son visage va apparaître dans
l'écran personne n'est venu vous voir
visage visite chic
[Rires]
quel est le rapport avec la soupe de
langues cher voire tu vas voir ce
qu'elle vous l'avez reconnu c'est qui
wayne dallas on ne reconnaît pas bien
sûr non écrit via le nom et amis se sont
arrêtés
le droit donc c'est tantôt de la belle
et ses princes
il est dans les marseillais galerie les
beaux gosses oui m j'aime bien en tout
alors on va vous et à manier tout
récapitulative manawi 6 et 11 tony a
quelque chose à vous dire ce soir où là
est ce que kelly a menti dit kylie
minogue ne sais quelle langue saï saï
koala non je mangeais médaille
[Musique]
et
j'y voyais c'était une jolie philippe et
on a plaisanté un peu hanté chez kevin
je suis fou amoureux
[Musique]
cette histoire c'était il y a environ 3
4 mois
il a ajouté sur snapshots on s'est parlé
pendant une ou deux semaines deux trois
semaines
il est très gentil et très respectueux
merci en tout cas où toute la vérité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous voulez savoir ce qu a
cogné à vous dire bien sûr alors espère
l'ouverture de rideau va prendre une
dizaine de minutes forcément cette barre
sont gelés et les retourner vous
cadets on va voir leurs rideaux ouvrez
moi ce rideau
[Applaudissements]
voilà là ok
merci d'être là
aridi s'est renchérie merci des talents
chanter dans le couloir alors antho t'es
venu très content de te rencontrer mercy
moi aussi ça fait plaisir d'être ici est
que j'aime beaucoup
ah ouais nan vraiment j'aime beaucoup je
l' ai déjà dit ici j'aime beaucoup tous
les gars qui font les marchés toutes les
filles aussi de cette très sympathique
après l'émission et telle autre paire de
manches j'ai mal aimés mais vous je vous
adore
alors il de loin comme ça je suis venu
pour thouars écoute voilà la haye les
deux traits sont j'ai pas justin bieber
mais je suis venu avec un bouquet de
fleurs parce que je suis pas rancunier
j'ai entendu ce que tu as dit sur le
plateau
tu vois tu as dit que voilà j'étais il
n'y avait pas d'atomes crochus sache que
moi j'en ai mais moi j'en ai beaucoup
mais oui moi je suis là pas montré je
n'ai peut-être pas montrer parce que je
suis un peu timide et parce que voilà
mais en mini en vrai j'avais beaucoup
d'atomes crochus pour toi toi tu en
avais pas donc là j'étais un peu dégoûté
forcément le mec tu vois on dirait que
ça m'a brisé le coeur me suis dit la
vérité tu as vu sur snapshot je m'en
fous moi j'ai pas de pudeur un
shakespeare est grave
j'ai pas de pudeur je viens de vendre
tout le monde voit la wii sur snapshot
j'ai dit qu'elle y vit de mulet vdo
velits pardon chez amoureux voilà un
champ je ne sais pas les vexer l'an
passé sur plateau mois pour moi c'est
censé être la langue de bois c'est la
plus belle fille que j'ai jamais vue à
la télé depuis ces dix dernières années
je te dis ça alors que t'as pas vu des
paroles chabot niveau meuf croyez moi je
me connais je fais de la télé réalité
donc j'en vois passer je peux vous le
dire que je me connais mais non mais non
mais non mais en vrai en vrai ce que je
veux dire que célibataire toi moi je
suis célibataire
ce que je peux te dire que non mais
elles mutilent et célibataire louis moi
aussi je suis célibataire
il est célibataire en ce moment à ouais
merci c'est un vrais gens me nous
connaît bien en taux et les célibataires
c'est un grand sentimental on dit merci
à jean louis et j'invite maintenant
layton apparemment voilà donc on a le
spécialiste des boîtes de nuit
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors en tôt qu'est-ce que tu es venu
d'irak était venue dire que tu l'as qui
fait vraiment ouais non un vrai nom mais
on va le prendre
c'est la première fois qu'on voit c'est
la vérité tu vois après je le prends
avec beaucoup d'autodérision de beaucoup
de second degré ça me fait plaisir
d'être ici en vrai déjà dit deux choses
tu as dit que tu avais pas d'atomes
crochus
tu peux comprendre tu vois après une
seconde chose ça m'a un peu embêté on va
dire tu vois tu as dit qu'il avait un
petit zizi non on est là on a dit c'est
le prime de la vérité c'est vrai ou pas
on est là pour dire la vérité at il eu
d'accord et moi j'ai envie de dire des
vérités ce soir et quand je vois kelly
kim jee on n'a pas forcément eu d'atomes
crochus ce qui est peut-être le cas et
ça je peux le comprendre
deuxième chose tu as 10 par rapport il y
avait des gens qui disaient que ce soit
sur les réseaux sociaux qu'on se parle
et c'est ce que tu m'as dit vrai ou pas
oui j'étais les gens regardaient
beaucoup les personnes que je suis vert
et certains dérangera que je voulais pas
qu'on voit ça me dérangeait parce
qu'après l'envoi de questions je veux
tester du jeu les prix un genre min
non je n'ai pas dit gens pensent que
parce que peut-être je viens du milieu
de la télé réalité
voilà je sais que pour ici peut-être
c'est mal vu alors moi je vais te dire
alors en fait c'est pas parce que je
fais de la terra mair un tourteau
dis-moi zerelli si rien est mal vu bon
on respecte tout le monde mais après je
pars pas duré et il ya des gens qui font
la témérité qui sont des gens très bien
comme la plupart des gens qui ont la
télé réalité 2 sont des gens très bien
où j'en ai ramassé des absents je veux
pas qu'on fasse l'amalgamé en fait
ai-je bien mais y'a pas je crois que tu
es une fille très bien je ne leur ai
jamais dit aussi honnêtement si c'était
parce que j'avais alors le cleri moi je
voudrais accélérée tout ça parce que la
wii car à ce rythme là vous peixoto en
2022 cyril du coup ça va je suis venu je
suis venu ouais tu m'a invité je suis
venu maintenant j'aimerais que tu me
fasses une fleur dis moi j'aimerais que
tu nous invites au resto tous les deux
ce soir et qu'on imagine
bon d'accord
aussant creveur double de menus toute
façon devenu si des bateaux n'arrivent
plus à tort comme des grèves plus aucun
amour des gens d'ici je vais te dire la
vérité en tout 10 avec plaisir vous
allez aller dîner ensemble
ok mais pas ce soir parce que juste ça
va faire le grand pardon j'ai le temps
mais est ce que tu veux dîner avec elle
est ce qu'elle peut dîner demain et
quant aux alémaniques écoutent regardent
un film qui a vu la motivation du oui
d'accord alors mais alors demain c'est
pour moi aller ça et je vous dire vous
allez flotte chez manger léger manger
[Rires]
aux cô tés une photo posée
dis moi tu qui parce que tu es censé un
clic tu as vraiment vide à séduire non
vraiment j'ai été sincère avec elle
voilà donc là on a glissé plus parler
donc maintenant c'est compliqué de dire
voilà tu m'as beaucoup plus je te l'aï
dit mais non ça s'est pas fait c'est
comme ça c'est la vie alors antho je
veux dire la vérité je crois je crois
que qu'edith qui fait bien mais qu'elle
dit est ce que tu pourrais avoir un
crush pour antho est-ce que ce dîner ne
va mener à rien et cas de l'amitié dans
ce cas là je reprends mes 20 euros voilà
et éventuellement vous verrez vous
appellerez au moins ça coûtera 12 n ya
personne
dis la vérité je peux pas privé c'est
déjà parlé en quoi je sais très bien que
voilà non alors vérité doit on pas ce
flux mon âge augmente plus je me dis
qu'il faut pas juger que par le physique
mais aussi ce qu'il ya à l'intérieur
d'accord on évolue comme ça dans la
jusqu'à l'intérieur soit tu vois pas
trop laisser de chance quand même parce
qu'on s'est pas vu qu était alors allé à
l'est et donc au final je suis beau mais
je me dis que pourquoi pas apprendre à
le connaître
non mais ce qu'il a une chance avec toi
et je sais pas je ne connais dans
barrette on s'était arrêté conejo c'est
aussi un petit peu
si tu vois un mec qui te plaît pas du
tout c'est que c'est pas ton délire ou
pas ça peut être mon élan alors y'a
combien de % de chances que ce soit ton
délire 6% c'est sûr sont alors j'irai 70
[Applaudissements]
mais le plus important d'entre elles
montrent qu'ils vous parlez merde
bondues reprendre ton billet quoi
reprendre ton billet il n'empêchera pas
tellement con way je pense que il ya peu
de chance demain